10 mai 1974 Valéry Giscard d'Estaing
affronte François Mitterrand lors d'un
débat télévisé pendant l'entrée de Tours
c'est la première fois qu'un tel
événement est organisé entre deux
candidats à la présidentielle mesdames
Messieurs le débat entre les deux
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
monsieur Valéry Giscard d'Estaing et
Monsieur François Mitterrand ouvre la
campagne électorale à l'ORTF cette idée
vient tout droit des États-Unis l'ORTF
décide de s'en inspirer et propose
l'idée aux deux candidats
quelques heures plus tôt au studio 101
de la Maison de la Radio les techniciens
s'activent pour tout préparer
[Musique]
un décollage un tout petit peu de la
feutrine un petit coup de trucs tu es
chef des couture de ça le réalisateur
installe minutieusement les micros des
deux candidats et l'éclairage
dur pour l'un et puis un éclairage très
doux pour l'autre c'est encore
inconcevable il peut fine également son
cadrage mais l'alternance des plans je
m'y emploierai de façon rigoureuse sera
identique c'est-à-dire qu'à un gros plan
de lin pour répondre à un gros plan de
lot 20h Valéry Giscard d'Estaing et
François Mitterrand arrivent dans le
studio voilà tout est en place
maintenant y compris les fameux
chronomètre électroniques avant que les
candidats ne prennent la parole les deux
journalistes Jacqueline Baudrier et
Alain Duhamel énumère les consignes du
débat notre rôle à Jacqueline Baudrier
et à moi-même sera essentiellement de
veiller
au respect du temps de parole de chacun
et puis au bon déroulement du débat pas
de question 45 minutes de temps de
parole chacun et des thèmes discutés au
préalable monsieur Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing le tirage au sort vous a
désigné pour ouvrir cette discussion
donc vous avez la parole à ce moment-là
de la campagne les sondages les annonce
à égalité ce débat est donc un réel
enjeu pour tous les deux et il en
restera 7 phrases vous n'avez pas
monsieur Mitterrand le monopole du cœur
vous n'avez pas le débat dure 1h30 et 25
millions de téléspectateurs suivent cet
événement en direct le lendemain du
débat la journaliste détaille l'attitude
des deux candidats ils étaient
évidemment au début de l'entretien assez
tendu il le cachait fort bien mais on
sentait même un peu d'anxiété Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing gagne un point et demi
dans les sondages les électeurs l'ont
trouvé plus sympathiques plus claires et
plus sincères
le 19 mai 1974 dans un second tour
extrêmement serré il est élu avec
50,81% des suffrages
[Musique]